hello
in this form mike's grabbed me here by
the lapel who knows what he's up to here
he might hit me or have a weapon he's
going to stab me so i want to quickly
move away
my initial attempt is simply to get away
and hit him in the face like this and
i'd like to have broken free here
this guy's got a good grip and he's
fairly tenacious so as i come in i don't
break that grip
i quickly shoot underneath his arm this
way
now just by the fact that he's grabbing
me he's created a santio for himself
i'm going to go ahead and grab that and
if he were to come back towards me
he'll apply sankyo to himself here i'm
using the sunkyo and the timing
to strike and move him back as his elbow
drops
i come to the top of the elbow and
pulling down my inside knee sinks i'm
already putting pressure on the shoulder
here
my free hand comes around and grabs the
sankyo i begin dropping this leg
which levers his shoulder and applies
the sunkeel at the same time
more time to speak hey
hi
yep munet dori song
you